we are a small family firm I'm Natasha
cell formation I mean Siva started by my
great-grandfather in 1925 Chinglish at
London's Park Theatre is a comedy about
the cultural differences between East
and West sadly for East Asian actors
roles like this are rare this rose got
so much complexity that actually I can
feel that I can really really melt
myself into the row but there are not
many rows like that so that's very
frustrating in the last decades the arts
have come a long way in terms of
promoting diversity yet when it comes to
casting East Asian actors say they're
still woefully underrepresented
campaigners say what's still going on is
whitewashing there were protests only
recently about the print rooms all-white
casting for a play set in China
featuring Chinese characters this is
major Hollywood stands accused of being
stuck in the past was still letting
white actors take on East Asian roles
many fans of the Japanese anime classic
ghost in the shell' were outraged too
that Scarlett Johansson was cast as the
film's lead rather than as Japanese
actor Tilda Swinton had to defend her
casting as the ancient one in dr.
strange a role that's shown as a male to
bettan monk in Marvel Comics
it's really important that people talk
about how important it is that Hollywood
cinema in in particular more accurately
reflects the diversity of the world we
all live in we need them to understand
the reasons
in fact why the ancient one was was
reimagined as someone who I might play
was precisely to disrupt these rather
not just racial stereotypes of the old
Asian geezer sitting on a hill passing
down wisdom to the white hero and so it
was actually in order to extend
diversity as Marvel is so committed to
doing more often than not East Asian
actors argue they're either overlooked
or forced to play stereotypes what I
would love our industry to be doing is
is representing in the mainstream what
it what is actually true of reality and
I would hope that any theatre company or
artistic directors or producers realize
that putting on works from minority
groups is not a risk it's a wonderful
opportunity like China to see cau
untapped talent at the moment critics
say that message of diversity somehow
still getting lost in translation
Kati Spencer Sky News